où
peu
nous défendrons la liberté que vous
enseignez si bien et nous porterons or
la laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs
[Musique]
q
la cabosse les mêmes parcours de la lyre
terme au débat
à terme on m'a battu ana
[Musique]
oui
on
[Musique]
il
nous
[Musique]
on
iphone 5 euros i wanna do bumba massa
darâa envahissent la france y sont
abolis au beverly wishire aussi à au
bihar aussi
[Musique]
m
c'est nous
grâce à des marques à la mode c'est un
all in mind your sa peine les chiffres
du bourg d'un demi litre mais c'est nul
ça qu'une française marc allard à auzat
il termine mon la recette l'homme
[Musique]